♪ (ROCK MUSIC FADES IN) ♪
Hello, everybody!
Maybe you noticed this isn't
like a regular concert.
The show is about our history
as Americans.
That history is in our songs.
(CROWD CHEERING)
I knew I wanted to do
the whole show
as a 24-hour performance.
But I only wanted
to do it once.
Today, tonight, and tomorrow.
SPEAKER:
It's a 24-hour performance
that asked us to practice joy
and exuberance
and maximalism.
I got totally inspired.
It was like, "Oh, my God.
I get to make 24 historical,
like, period costumes."
TAYLOR MAC:
Part of the art was that
the audience would be with us
for 24 hours, as well.
♪ War, children ♪
♪ It's just a shot away
It's just a shot away ♪
SPEAKER 2:
Taylor's created something
that is a radical format.
Gloria, Gloria!
♪ Gloria, Gloria! ♪
TAYLOR MAC: The audience,
they start to support us more.
We lose energy on stage,
but they give more energy.
♪ It is decreed
The people rule ♪
I'm interested in what happens
when the audience has to make
a commitment to something.
It stops being
just a party game.
It becomes something deeper.
♪ (UKELELE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
The reason we have problems
is lack of community.
♪ When all the artists
Leave or die ♪
An artist's job is
to dream the culture forward.
♪ And you're alone ♪
To look at the things
that aren't working in society
and imagine
how it could be better.
♪ You can lie down ♪
Ultimately, for me,
it's all about
experiencing the full range
of who you are
and taking the time
to actually do that.
♪ You can lie down
Or get up and play ♪
(CROWD SINGS) ♪ You can lie down